[Music]
uh seen a couple more people have been
trashing uh
trash and uh brandon
what why
because he's a real piece of [ __ ]
uh here look check this out he didn't do
anything though
he certainly didn't put together a funny
special i could tell you that uh here
check this out
oh so bad huh it's so bad i'll never
honestly he he has ruined the the word
pico
because now every time i go to a mexican
restaurant i'm not going to be able to
help myself i'll just be like yeah could
i get um just a couple chicken tacos
please
maybe some tostones and uh some pickles
[Laughter]
can't help it he's ruined it
you know i i
i don't like being in conflict with
other people
anyone
he's terrified of conflict with kittens
yeah he is especially because you know
we're we are a community you know
sadly they're doing the [ __ ]
comedians our community like you guys
are [ __ ] civilians yeah yeah shut up
we're part we're part of a brotherhood
much like the marine corps yeah i mean
i'm sure there's a lot of people that
were making fun of podcasters now
they're having a podcast now huh mm-hmm
know that
i wish i could say this but i'm not it's
just it's just the n word you could say
it if you wanted to yeah you're chinese
whatever whatever what is he korean
korean i just i just love
dude with hispanics and asians it's so
much fun always just like getting their
country wrong because they always are
offended like i don't know what you're
like puerto rican or whatever you're
like oh yeah i don't know what do you
like chinese or something yeah they get
really yeah so man you want a japanese
guy to be mad call a japanese guy
chinese or korean they hate both they
[ __ ] hate both
who the filipinos hate
themselves
the chinese
everybody hates the chinese a lot of
them hate the chinese because the giant
because china's like the us of asia yeah
everyone everyone [ __ ] you know takes
pot shots at them
sorry i'm sorry mr korea
tell there's divisions
right so when this whole thing went down
you know my my phone i got texts from
allies
right and then
but then like
but this is okay
we formed an alliance mind you i'm on
bobby the side here in this of this
whole thing honestly i really am and i
like bobby lee i like bobby lee we agree
we like him and he's funny but he's
still from l.a yeah he can't help but he
can't help it you're right he can't help
it he can't escape the la comic-ism the
only person who has that superpower is
theovonne yeah
accent yeah if theovonne didn't have the
accent i wouldn't like him as much but
the fact that he's sorry hey man hey man
i'm just trying to stay out of this dude
you know just trying to make money and
you know stay at everybody's way
yeah exactly
like there was a division can you say
who the allies are or no no no because
if i tell you the [ __ ] allies you're
going to just deduce and go all those no
no no you could because it's not like i
have a lot more allies that never call
because they know that i'm uncomfortable
and yeah they're so i could tell you
there's one ally that i heard that was
just a funny call that was
okay people are really trying to blow up
his [ __ ] spot here yeah and by the
way hey hey bobby when you do a podcast
you bully your producer you don't let
your producer bully you it's the other
way around he's like you see this he's
letting his producer [ __ ] bully him
yeah when does that ever happen no
frozen next time you go to your meeting
of producers that you guys go to and the
alps or whatever meeting of filipino
producers that's the meaning of filipino
the association of filipino podcast
producers
so just two yes you guys one three i
forgot
um
i forgot gomez has one yeah okay so
three all right there you go
he's like i gotta go to the afpp uh
convention this year
that's the yeah the association of
filipino podcast producers
it's like six of us
[Laughter]
so i'll tell you who did call because
this is how i am the funniest phone call
yeah everyone just interrupted right
after age three it was hilarious i'm
calling to threaten you is what he said
oh yeah yeah it was cigarra
tom segura except okay that's [ __ ] okay
god damn it that's actually very funny
sometimes a girl called him instead of
calling threaten you that's actually
something i would do to immerse if that
happened to him yeah if this it's any
similar situation if everybody was
picking on royce or frozen i would just
call be like yeah i'm calling scream at
you
don't ever [ __ ] do that again
the girl immediately after
he threatened me i'm calling to threaten
you
and i'm like come on man you know i mean
and he asked me how i was it was
hilarious i'm calling to threaten you is
what he's
i mean
that's funny i gotta give the girl that
that was yeah
it just i don't understand
[Laughter]
000 subs but he's like two buttons on on
on youtube and honestly his channel is
great because it's not just brandon shop
stuff but it's like
basically it's just la comic-centric and
what pieces of [ __ ] they are
you know like here look look here did
you see this new trash tuesday putting
yourself in the position to like knowing
the nasty stuff because it's like when i
moved to la i hung up the comedy store
till 3am every night for like a year and
a half and it's like yeah you just come
up
so let me guess when you when you hung
out at the comedy store were you maybe
i don't know how do i say this lightly
sucking comics dicks for stage time
i'm asking i'm not saying you were
but was that something that happens this
woman i i forget her name but she is i
knew who she was as soon as you hit play
because i couldn't see the video at
first but i knew she was white right
away that voice is just
crossed the wrong people at the wrong
time and they're like they're gross i am
still like
until the pandemic stops me that is
exactly what i've been doing for about
seven years
till three maybe but i think i sort of
did the same i used to any letterman's
becoming like a 60 year old jewish woman
yeah very quickly very fast yeah like
within a year yourself and being like
the bro
like the only girl that like dudes would
spill all their see and i felt really
now i feel really gross about it because
i'm like i don't want to know that
this is a lie and these are this is a
lie and this is a girl lie and girls
tell these lie like i didn't want it you
loved it because here's the thing if you
didn't want to know like if dudes were
spilling their secrets if these comics
were basically what what she means is
let me translate for you
some comics were talking [ __ ] about
other comics to her because she hung out
around the [ __ ] comedy store right
and then now she's going like i felt
dirty i didn't even want to know those
things shut the [ __ ] up because if you
wanted that you know what i would do
like if mercer's telling me something
and this person wasn't around and i
would be like hey man you know what i i
don't care like don't don't be
i don't really care i don't want to get
in the middle of this [ __ ] like whatever
leave me alone you know but instead you
sat there and you listened to all the
dirt you got dirt on everybody you
probably make little snide jokes about
it and now she's now she's being like i
never even wanted to be put in that
position
it was so hard for me to actually have
comics talk [ __ ] about each other but
you were talking all that good [ __ ] and
having having a good laugh about it
weren't you
i'll never out anybody but i'll say that
i know a lot of comics and i don't know
one of them that thinks pretty trump is
funny
[ __ ] on the side
yeah and but then my my therapist was
like why do you feel some type of way
about it it's not yours yeah it's not
yours
and it's it is weird
though like i remember seeing this one
guy who like is there anything worse
than listening to three women talking
listen about anything listen to three
women talk about brendan chop
a guy who like cheats on his [ __ ]
girl all the time
and he's hit on you yeah this guy has
hit him yeah he slid into my head
like slitting his idea
yeah you need to reevaluate a hair loss
i mean we've had a couple conversations
and it just never went there
these comedians don't want me
no you're [ __ ] self-realization
wow
what a self-realization she just had the
the old the frump is really mad that
she's not getting sexually harassed by
the way this is how women really think
deep down
like wow they want to be sexually
harassed
because if they're not and they're like
what was annoying
talk about talk about am i not pretty
enough did you see the light bulb
go off i'm not pretty enough to suck his
dick in his raptor truck
you know it has the same engine as a as
a gt mustang then we know
okay
uh if you look at the back it has
branding it actually says raptor under
ford whoa
you want to blow me in it no it's okay
all right you want to blow me outside of
it
sir the location is not the problem
yo dog i heard you like getting your
dick sucked so i'm gonna suck your dick
in your truck
like damn exhibit why is it even trying
to suck my dick exhibit's just trying to
get re-revitalize his career during
pride month yeah he knows it's the
easiest way to get press pimp my pride
it's not just the comedians esther we're
glad you're here today we wanted to tell
you
but anyway so yeah so i i see this guy
with his like family
and at the mall and i felt so guilty
what mall is it
century city yeah
and but it was what i'm sorry
why would that matter
for
in this story i think this is the story
kind of that started it all why by the
way what we're playing here but
we've never played it
why would what mall is like if we first
were to go to be hey man i went to the
mall
and bro somebody shot me and my first
thing wasn't like are you okay it would
be like what mall
okay which which one which small were
you shot at was it the outlets or the
actual or like the air-conditioned mall
was just lavender
did it have like enough about the mall
dude did it have an amc 24 or 13.
dude can i get to the point where i was
shot no
i felt like my face was like hot when i
met and it wasn't like i've done nothing
i've only rejected this person's
advances
i've never like seen him hook up with
anyone else i just know from the way he
talks to me that he talks to everyone
else like this
and it was just hi ma'am it's called
being a guy
i i
i am not defending brendan here okay
but also
she's shocked that a dude's acting like
a dude you know what i mean like she's
just like i can't believe it
i hung out with all these scumbag
[ __ ] comics
and i am now just all of these women are
realizing something in this episode
because obviously we all know the start
of the whole brennan shop thing and it's
just [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] and he's an idiot
but also it's funny watching the
self-realization like nobody hits on me
to like and i felt bad because i didn't
realize that every comedian's a [ __ ]
scumbag you know what difference between
how they comic and a new york comic is
they're both scumbags but the new york
comic will tell you that he's won that's
it right
yeah and i'm sorry but if i'm inviting
any one of these [ __ ] back to hang
out you think it's because i think
you're so funny that you're
like you think oh man let's go out
sometime for the amazing conversation in
camaraderie
nice word camaraderie yeah well they're
a brotherhood rice i know their
community
[ __ ] hate the comedians think about
themselves that way
just so i mean i was just bright red i i
mean i pulled it off i made some joke
about i pulled it up did you see her did
you see that
i mean i totally pulled it off though
i'm so cool
you got a rich guy that's what i'm
saying it's like that secondhand like
embarrassment or that secondhand guilt
that shouldn't even be guilt but it's
there because you just happen to be like
the object of their like you know what i
mean right but then it's like the
trouble you'd be in if you you were the
person like pulled them aside and were
like hey oh yeah that would just and it
never you always so does this chick just
hold her dog all the time yes that's
like her thing
i'm like it's probably probably an
emotional support animal chick is
probably
the out of all three of these chicks i
guarantee you the one with the dog is
the most broken oh yeah absolutely you
do that you never ever ever
help this that's oh the girl will like
call you a liar or whatever you know
it's just like such a wonderful it is
also not your business to do that
yeah but it is
be in other female comics you talk about
this it's like we're put in an
uncomfortable position when people are
coming out are you ever funny
i mean i like to think i am sometimes
not shut up
it was with their like
mistresses or whatever and like what are
we supposed to do like i don't know it
just it puts everybody in an
uncomfortable this is why women
shouldn't be involved in things though
can i i was just gonna say i could solve
this problem in one stroke yeah women
get out of just get out of all these
little boys clubs
there you go i i just it and look and
here's the thing if you are going to be
part of it then you can't then do this
right
because this is how a guy handles it
yeah hey man
it's brilliant it's brendan shop yeah
he's with some other chick yeah but
isn't he like married though yeah yeah
man that's like whatever dude it's none
of my business
and that's it and then you move on and
you move on it's none of my business
dude yeah and this is like well it is
but we talk us in other female comics
and you shut up
we have a moral obligation to our
sisters to like no you don't
i don't want to hear it man amy schumer
literally sucked comedy out of anthony
justin's next dick which got her a movie
and then people realize she [ __ ]
sucks
so
and i've had people confront me before
about knowing something that was going
on in their relationship
and
pretty much the argument that works for
me is going all right let's say i told
you
what would you have done
would you a would you believe me b if i
told you and you did believe me you'd
probably still stay with the [ __ ] and
then she'd hate me and then you'd start
hating me right so it's like
what do you how do you think that would
have played out something
but i i think that you know
unless we're like good friends but
that's the problem is these people all
think like
they they know deep down they're not
good friends but they have to do this
like we're like a brotherhood and you
know we gotta look out for [ __ ] no you
know you guys don't even like each other
you know you [ __ ] are all in a
competing business right you're all a
product
this is like the iphone and the samsung
getting along
like we got to get along because we're
in the same industry no you're not
you're competing products
it's a [ __ ] standalone business
that's funny then why do all the social
media outlooks work together to [ __ ]
get make sure conservatives are kicked
off of their platforms
well that's because they're not actually
a product or a business um they're an
enemy tool of control yeah speaking of
the upcoming
best yep by far well smashing with you
well you know okay
up in there yeah oh yeah ken has a
throwback by the way but it's worth it's
worth pointing out because it's kind of
like really puts the whole thing
together this is the one where brendan's
like keeps interrupting and he's totally
lost i remember this there you go gone
for god's sakes right now so but still
he's still in the mix right is he in the
middle no he just got you know he came
back
no contract but is he done i don't know
he he said right now he's focused on uh
the nacho libre stuff and then he's
gonna you know watch your mouth man is
that what's called nacho libra i'm not
even trying to be funny
don't worry brandon i've never confused
you with somebody who was trying to be
funny
nacho libre's the movie
he is
profoundly [ __ ]
like i love how he said that look we've
nacho libra
we've probably seen this years ago it
doesn't matter it's one of those i just
love it
yeah that's a joke
watching somebody in real time
lost he he look he's just
right you know what brenda reminds me of
brandon reminds me of like
how i am if i take a really bad hit of
weed and i disassociate for a second
right or if i'm starting to have a panic
attack but i don't have a full-blown
panic attack
and i come back out of it and like i was
in a conversation and now i'm lost and
i'm and i'm trying to just [ __ ] my
way back in like oh [ __ ]
all right i don't want to worry this
person yeah no nacho libre that was the
movie
like that was fine that was 10 minutes
ago you're like oh i'm sorry where am i
oh no
bring it bro
okay here you go hold on hold on hold on
oh
bring it bro you're gonna get attacked
online you better watch yeah they come
up for you bro oh no
bring it bro bring it bro bring it bro
bring it bro
okay well
sir it has been brought in and now
you're trying to uh as i was just social
media
now you're and now you're trying to go
after uh
that's why i don't do sensamelia anymore
because sentiment yeah because people
are all like you know mean on the
internet yeah no i don't blame you well
you know what good luck we got to make
up our own brendan shaw business yeah
like so social media should be since
amelia since to me i don't know
anymore well because it's not masculine
it's not
masculine masculinity
it's not that's it
it's not masking it's not a masking
thing to do honestly if you ask me
he's i love him
i hate him but i love him that's why
when people go who's worse brendan
schaab or this person i'm like i'll
never not enjoy brendan schub though the
other person is usually worse
and if you thought that segment was good
you should join our patreon because i'm
going to clip this just reminding myself
on air it's easier
um
you